Here’s a theory: Game Thrones is really
all about climate change.
Climate change
We are hurtling toward the day when climate
change could be irreversible.
Why it’s so bad, and why it’s so hard
to do anything about it.
Think about the White Walkers, those horrifying
monsters with the zombie army that killed
everyone in that crazy battle at Hardhome.
They’re an inhuman destructive force that
literally changes the weather during their
onslaught.
Like climate change, the White Walkers are
a threat to the whole human race. Noble houses
like the Starks, the Lannisters, the Baratheons,
the Martells, and the Boltons are too busy
fighting with each other over control of the
kingdom to come together over a common
threat. Sometimes, they even deny that White
Walkers are real.
I don’t believe that giants and ghouls and
White Walkers are lurking beyond the Wall.
You’ve probably seen charts of CO2 emissions
skyrocketing in the 20th and 21st centuries
as humans industrialized. And you’ve probably
also seen charts that show just how bad that’s
going to be if we don’t stop it.
Rising flood levels, droughts, ocean acidification.
Climate change is this massive global threat.
But stopping it requires the world’s biggest
nations —like China, India, and the US — to sacrifice
a little in the short term and put away their political competition with each other.
In the meantime, the world’s poorest people
— the Wildlings in the show — suffer.
And the experts in the real world, our own
Night’s Watch, stand on the sidelines.
That’s why Charli Carpenter, a political
scientist at the University of Massachusetts,
calls Game of Thrones a "collective action story"
"The story of the Northern Wall and the forces it holds at bay," she says, "is about the mistaken belief
that the industrial civilization can stand against the changing forces of nature."
People love yelling at the characters on the
show for ignoring the zombie threat in the
north. But if our zombies are climate change,
and we’re not doing nearly enough to prevent
catastrophic global warming, who should you really be annoyed with?